On a tous l'habitude de voir ou de toucher du sable,
c'est une matière qui nous est familière.
D'ailleurs on retrouve du sable
pas seulement sur les plages,
mais sur une bonne partie de la surface de la planète
et pourtant c'est une substance un peu étrange.
Quand on le regarde de près,
pas de doute, le sable est un solide.
Des petits grains, de la silice la plupart du temps,
qui sont comme de minuscules cailloux.
Mais si on en prend une poignée et bien le sable s'écoule,
on peut même le verser, presque comme si c'était un liquide.
Alors évidemment le sable ça n'est pas un liquide,
on voit bien d'ailleurs, on peut marcher sur le sable
alors qu'à priori, on ne peut pas marcher sur l'eau.
Autre différence avec un liquide,
quand on fait s'écouler du sable, il forme un tas.
Le sable est ce qu'on appelle
un milieu granulaire, constitué de grains
et qui se comporte à mi-chemin
entre un liquide et un solide.
Il a des propriétés bien particulières
qu'on ne comprend pas encore complètement
et ce n'est pas seulement pour le plaisir
de faire des châteaux de sable qu'on l'étudie.
On retrouve en effet des milieux granulaires
dans tout un tas d'applications,
qu'il s'agisse d'agriculture, de l'industrie agroalimentaire,
des matériaux de construction ou encore en géophysique,
pour mieux comprendre des phénomènes
comme des avalanches ou des éboulements.
Commençons par cette constatation
qui distingue le sable d'un liquide.
Quand on le verse, il forme un tas.
Généralement, ce tas est un cône
avec un certain angle à la base
et ce qui est étonnant, c'est que pour un sable donné,
quelle que soit la quantité,
l'angle semble toujours le même
et si on essaie d'imposer un angle plus élevé,
le tas revient à son angle initial.
Mais qu'est-ce qui détermine la valeur de cet angle ?
Pour l'étudier de manière précise, on peut faire
un petit montage avec un cylindre tournant.
L'idée est de remplir le cylindre à moitié ou un peu moins
et de le faire tourner lentement à l'horizontale pour
observer l'angle à partir duquel le sable s'écoule.
Si on ne fait pas ça à la plage, mais en laboratoire
avec un montage approprié
on constate qu'il y a en réalité deux angles.
Celui à partir duquel l'avalanche
se déclenche appelé "angle d'avalanche"
et celui auquel elle se stabilise appelé "angle de repos".
Ces angles vont varier avec la nature du sable
et dépendent principalement de la forme des grains
et de leur rugosité en surface,
mais aussi, comme vous pouvez
vous en douter, de l'humidité du sable.
Et oui, l'humidité joue clairement un rôle,
puisque si vous prenez du sable mouillé,
tout le monde sait qu'on peut faire un château,
c'est-à-dire en quelque sorte, un tas
dont l'angle à la base est 90°... ou presque.
Pour comprendre ce qu'il se passe avec un château
de sable, il faut comprendre le rôle de l'eau.
Quand il y a peu d'eau dans votre sable,
celle-ci vient se placer entre les grains
et crée une force d'attraction qu'on appelle la force capillaire.
C'est en gros la même force qui fait que le rideau
de douche en plastique, quand il est mouillé,
va coller sur la baignoire ou bien sur votre peau.
Cette force capillaire assure la cohésion des grains de sable.
Pour qu'une structure en château de sable fonctionne bien,
il faut qu'il y ait suffisamment d'eau pour créer
tous ces petits ponts capillaires entre les grains,
mais pas trop, parce que s'il commence à y avoir des
poches d'eau, la structure s'affaiblit et peut s'effondrer,
donc il y a un niveau d'humidité optimal.
Dans une publication de 2012, des physiciens
se sont amusés à chercher cet optimum
et ils ont trouvé environ 1% d'eau
en volume par rapport au sable,
pour des grains d'environ 100 microns.
En plus de ça, ils ont montré que quand on se place à l'optimum,
on peut construire des structures aussi hautes que
celles qu'on pourrait faire avec un matériau solide normal
et que la hauteur maximale avant
que la tour ne deviennent instable
dépend du diamètre de la base selon une formule classique.
Avec ça, ils ont construit par exemple des structures de
1m de haut avec une base de seulement 7cm de diamètre.
Une des propriétés étonnante du sable,
c'est que quand il est suffisamment bien tassé,
si on essaye de le déformer, cela le conduit à se détasser,
c'est-à-dire qu'il se dilate quand on le déforme et c'est assez contre-intuitif.
Généralement, quand vous exercez une pression
sur un solide poreux, par exemple du pain,
il va plutôt se contracter et pas se dilater.
Cette propriété étonnante du sable est appelée
la dilatance et il en existe une illustration bien connue.
Quand vous marchez sur du sable mouillé,
juste à la marée descendante,
vous pouvez constater que le sable devient blanc sous vos pas
et bien c'est à cause de ça, le sable est initialement bien tassé
et quand vous le déformez sous vos pieds,
il ne peut que se dilater.
Comme il augmente de volume, l'eau qu'il contient
doit se répartir sur ce volume plus grand,
à cet endroit, le sable devient donc moins humide
et s'éclaircit légèrement
avant que l'eau alentour ne viennent
remplir les interstices à nouveau.
Mais voici une autre expérience assez spectaculaire
qui joue sur cet effet de dilatance.
Pour la faire, il va vous falloir un verre,
un bâton et bien sûr du sable.
Placez le bâton verticalement dans le verre au milieu,
tenez-le et remplissez de sable sec, pas humide.
Tapez légèrement sur le bord du verre pour bien tasser
le sable et recommencez deux ou trois fois.
Quand le verre est plein, soulevez le bâton
et là, surprise, le verre vient avec,
il est comme solidaire du bâton.
La raison, c'est que quand le sable s'est tassé,
les grains ont formé des arches,
un peu comme dans une clé de voûte
et pour que le bâton puisse sortir, le sable
doit se dilater et il n'a pas la place de le faire.
Pour annuler l'effet, vous remuez
juste un peu le bâton comme ça,
ça libère la structure et le bâton peut sortir du verre.
Voyons maintenant un autre type d'expérience
avec un objet qui nous est familier, un sablier.
Vous savez peut-être qu'il existe un objet analogue
au sablier, mais avec du liquide,
ce qu'on appelle une clepsydre.
Bien que le sable soit une substance plus complexe que l'eau,
pour le coup, un sablier est plus simple
à utiliser qu'une clepsydre.
On va faire une petite comparaison.
J'ai pris une bouteille percée avec
des graduations pour mesurer le volume,
on va la remplir successivement de sable et d'eau
et on va comparer le temps qu'ils mettent pour s'écouler.
Ce qu'on constate, c'est que le temps que met le sable à
s'écouler ne semble pas dépendre de la hauteur du sable.
Pour chaque niveau de graduation,
on a à peu près la même durée.
Au contraire, l'eau s'écoule bien plus vite au début qu'à la fin.
Ça se sent d'ailleurs avec la pression du jet.
La vitesse d'écoulement du sable est constante
et c'est d'ailleurs bien pratique, ça veut dire que
si la moitié du sable s'est écoulé,
la moitié du temps est passé et ça
ce n'est plus vrai avec un liquide comme l'eau.
La première moitié de l'eau
va s'écouler plus vite que la deuxième.
On peut faire une analyse précise du phénomène.
Avec l'eau c'est facile, on sait calculer
que la vitesse d'écoulement est égale à racine de 2gh,
où g est l'accélération de la gravité et h la hauteur de l'eau.
Donc l'eau s'écoulera plus vite au début,
quand la hauteur est élevée, qu'à la fin.
Dans le cas du sable, on peut montrer
que la vitesse est proportionnelle à racine de gR,
où R est le rayon du trou.
Pour le sable, la vitesse d'écoulement ne dépend
donc pas de la hauteur restant dans la bouteille,
elle est tout le temps la même
elle dépend juste de la taille de l'ouverture.
Si on observe ou qu'on simule dans les détails ce qu'il se passe,
on constate que dans le sable se créent des structures,
un peu comme les arches dont on parlait tout à l'heure
et qui font que seule une petite portion
autour du trou est mise en mouvement
et que ces grains de sable en bas ne sentent pas,
en quelque sorte, la pression du dessus
car celle ci est reprise par les arches qui se forment.
Une dernière petite expérience amusante pour la route.
Comme c'est l'été, vous allez peut-être prendre l'apéro
et il y a un phénomène bien connu des physiciens
de comptoir, c'est ce qu'on appelle "l'effet noix du Brésil".
C'est l'idée que, dans un paquet contenant
un mélange de noix et autres cacahuètes diverses,
les noix du Brésil les plus grosses
ont toujours tendance à remonter à la surface,
ce qui est un peu contre-intuitif, on a tendance à se dire
qu'en étant plus grosses, elles devraient aller au fond.
On peut reproduire ce type de phénomène de manière
un peu plus contrôlée en utilisant du sable,
en plaçant au fond un gros caillou et en tapant.
...
Et voilà, étonnamment, bien que plus lourd
le gros caillou est remonté en surface,
ce qui est quand même un peu bizarre.
Il y a deux explications à ce phénomène.
La première est assez intuitive, quand on secoue
l'ensemble, ça libère temporairement sous le gros caillou
un petit espace dans lequel les petits grains
de sable peuvent venir se glisser
et donc peu à peu forcer le caillou à remonter.
Mais il y a un autre phénomène qui rentre en jeu
et qu'on appelle la convection granulaire.
C'est le fait que quand on agite le récipient,
il se crée un mouvement global des grains
qu'on ne voit pas forcément toujours très bien
et où les grains proches des parois descendent,
tandis que ceux vers le centre remontent,
on parle de convection.
Ce mouvement de rouleau entraîne
le gros caillou jusqu'à la surface
et ensuite, peut même le faire replonger près des parois.
...
Alors l'effet est amusant pour l'apéro,
mais sachez que le comprendre
a de vraies implications pour un certain nombre d'applications,
par exemple, chaque fois qu'on doit mélanger
des milieux granulaires de tailles différentes,
ce qui arrive dans l'industrie agroalimentaire
ou par exemple pour les matériaux de construction.
Vous voyez donc que l'étude des milieux granulaires
est un domaine passionnant
où on peut à la fois rapprocher de la science fondamentale
et des applications pratiques tout à fait concrètes.
Si toutes ces histoires de fluide
et de presque fluide vous amusent,
je vous recommande d'aller faire un tour
sur la chaîne du Projet Lutétium.
C'est une chaîne tenue par des étudiants en physique et en art
et qui propose plein de belles expériences de ce genre
et je crois savoir de source sûre qu'ils préparent
quelque chose sur le thème des milieux granulaires.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, comme d'habitude
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner,
à la partager, à la faire connaitre autour de vous,
mettre des pouces bleus,
il parait que les pouces bleus, c'est important,
la cloche, Facebook, Twitter, tout ça
et puis si jamais vous ne l'avez pas déjà lu sur la plage,
vous pouvez aller jeter un coup d’œil à mon bouquin
qui s'appelle "Insoluble mais vrai".
On se retrouve très bientôt pour
des nouvelles vidéos un peu plus lourdes
et dans un contexte un peu moins estival, à bientôt.